[Music]
over the past week or so including today
we've discussed uh
issues relating to abortion a few times
and that's where the new cycle has taken
us though even apart from the new cycle
uh it is one of the central issues of
our time and has for that reason always
been a central concern of mine
now the focus on this topic recently has
provoked many people to leave all kinds
of comments and send me messages making
all sorts of really bad arguments
against my position
and i address some of those arguments as
presented by people on tick tock
i think that was last week but there's
one argument that i've not addressed
recently
and it's perhaps worth devoting some
attention to because many people seem to
find it persuasive
at least four different people over the
last week have brought this up to me
and the argument varies a little bit
depending on who is making it but the
theme and the point is always the same
so i'll pull one of these at random in
order to respond to it here is the
argument as articulated by someone
in the comments on my show i think this
was yesterday and he wrote
quote okay thought experiment
there's a burning abortion clinic and
due to the very unusual circumstances
you find yourself in
you only have time to choose between
saving a perfectly healthy baby who's a
few weeks old or you could save a
mini-fridge
containing a thousand implanted eggs at
the very earliest stages
would you actually lose sleep over
saving the child instead of these 1 000
quote children now as i said this is a
popular argument you've probably heard
it before
sometimes it's a thousand embryos
sometimes it's 10 000 sometimes 500
sometimes there's a baby or a
five-year-old or a kid of some other age
in this case the commenter says a
thousand implanted eggs
in an abortion clinic for some reason
will assume he meant
embryos in an ivf clinic because
implantation
is when the egg attaches to the uterine
wall if there's a thousand of those then
there are a thousand pregnant women
and my question is why are they in a
freezer and also if i have time to save
a thousand pregnant women why can't i
save the baby too
but this is semantics perhaps we'll just
say embryos because that's the form the
argument usually takes
and the point here is obvious if you say
that the born
child if you say that you would save the
born child over the embryos then clearly
you must be affirming that there is some
sort of inherent
difference between the born child and
the embryo which reveals supposedly a
fundamental contradiction
in your pro-life position that is unless
you take more than 10 seconds to think
about the issue
which i have so here's how i would
break it down would i save the born baby
instead of the embryos
um yes absolutely no question
does that prove that my position on
abortion is wrong or contradictory or
logically weak
no absolutely not
and i'll tell you why a few things to
consider first
we're talking about emotions here okay
the decision of who to save in a burning
building
is is a is an emotional one that you
make more than it is a moral one
the reason we're put in a burning
building for the burning building for
this hypothetical
is to get us to forfeit our moral
reasoning and adopt emotional reasoning
emotional reasoning in a burnt in a
burning building is
okay in an abortion clinic it isn't
after all my personal
and emotional connection with my own
child
would lead me to save him over someone
else's
does that mean i don't recognize the
value of someone else's child or that it
would be okay for me to kill
someone else's child of course not
second point there's a really important
difference between leaving someone in a
burning building
because you can't save them and directly
killing them yourself
it is morally permissible to commit a
good act saving a child
which may indirectly lead to something
bad the embryos being destroyed
the intention in that case is to save
the child not to destroy the embryos
i'm not the one who's destroying the
embryos i didn't kill them i merely
failed to prevent them
from being killed and that's obviously a
really significant distinction it's why
if there are two
two people trapped in a fire and you run
in and save only one
you're not gonna be prosecuted for
murdering the one you didn't save
if anyone's prosecuted for murder it'll
be the person who set the fire
see an abortion on the other hand the
child is being killed
in a quote fire set by his parents
a choice is made to directly and
purposefully kill the child
it's a very different thing
third this thought experiment if it
measures anything at all
it measures how much i personally
would value the child over the embryos
but it doesn't matter how i value them
personally it's their intrinsic value
that matters
i value my family over your family
whoever you are i value my family over
yours
but your family has the same intrinsic
value see i'm making the decision based
as i said before on emotion
i can see the child i can hear him
crying i'm looking him in the eyes i
grab him it's instinct
there's also some logic to it i don't
really know how many of the embryos are
still
uh you know viable whether they're well
whether they'll ever be implanted and
given the chance to develop
i don't know these things again this
calculation would not justify killing
the embryos under any circumstance but
it would justify my
my decision to save the child instead
maybe i can get the point across with my
own thought experiment okay
you're in a burning building there's an
85 year old terminally ill cancer
patient
and a healthy five-year-old boy you
could only save one who do you choose
wouldn't everyone save the five-year-old
even the 85-year-old himself would
probably tell you to save the
five-year-old
is that because the 85 year old's life
has less value
does the fact that we would all
immediately choose the five-year-old
prove
anything at all about the intrinsic
value of elderly people
no it speaks only to the terrible and
morbid calculations we're forced to make
when we're put in a dire situation like
this
if i had if i had a choice to save my
own child
or 100 strangers
well i've got bad news for the strangers
and the news is not that they have no
moral worth or basic rights it's just
that
i'm dead and that's my kid and i'm not
leaving him to burn under any
circumstance
so that's how you deal with that
argument but notice something about the
pro-abortion side notice how they almost
always rely on these far-fetched
hypotheticals
you're in a burning ivf clinic you're
attached by tubes to a stranger etc etc
or they rely on extremely hard cases
like rape and incest
see what the pro-abortion side never
wants to talk about is the actual
reality
of abortion in almost every case because
in actual reality almost every time
there's no fire there hasn't been any
rape
there's just the child who was conceived
through an intentional act by the
parents and he's there now
and so is the mother and so is the
abortionist
and a choice is made that doesn't have
to be made
that's the reality so let's talk about
that
but that's the last thing that anybody
on the pro-abortion side actually wants
to talk about
which is why they are today yet again of
course cancelled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated